en medio de la intensa ola de calor que
vive francia la siembra de árboles es
una opción para protegerse de las altas
temperaturas
tranquilizante profesor y activista
medioambiental
recorre las calles de parís midiendo el
calor de diferentes terrenos
empieza frente al edificio de la famosa
ópera garnier la temperatura del asfalto
está entre 56 y 58 grados celsius porque
es un material que almacena mucho calor
entonces en algunos lugares el calor que
se siente es más intenso que en medio
del sáhara
ahora le dantec se desplaza por el
bulevar de los italianos una de las
zonas con más árboles de la capital
francesa tenemos alrededor de 28 grados
su termómetro aquí marcó 8 grados menos
lo que demuestra que la sombra de los
árboles refresca quién se posa en ella
pero parís tiene sólo un 10% de espacios
verdes muy por detrás de otras capitales
europeas como londres y oslo según datos
del world city scott ser form es por eso
que el ayuntamiento de la ciudad quiere
crear islas de frescura para 2026
plantando 170.000 árboles y cambiando el
cemento de varios patios escolares por
vegetación
a pesar de las promesas del ayuntamiento
tomás bale fundador de la ong grupo
nacional para el monitoreo de los
árboles denunció la tala masiva de
árboles el pasado mes de abril